how do you deploy this DeSantis model
because it's not just politics right
I've got a tweet here from clay Travis
you may have heard of this I think I
mentioned it as a throwaway on
yesterday's show
uh but clay says here NPR National
Public Radio announces it will no longer
use Twitter because Elon Musk has
correctly pointed out that taxpayer
dollars are used to support NPR it's
amazing how quickly left Wingers Run for
the hills when they actually face
scrutiny NPR should just build its own
internet that's how this works right and
here's the statement below from NPR
NPR's organizational accounts will no
longer be active on Twitter because the
platform is taking actions that
undermine our credibility by falsely
implying that we are not editorially
independent we are not putting our
journalism on platforms that have
demonstrated an interest in undermining
our credibility and the Public's
understanding of our editorial
Independence we are turning away from
Twitter but not from our audiences and
communities there are plenty of ways to
stay connected and keep up with NPR's
news music and cultural content uh well
this Elon Musk guy you know this Elon
Musk guy run Twitter he saw that and
here's what he tweeted
NPR literally said Federal funding is
essential to public radio on their
website now taken down what Hypocrites
so the point is guys whether it's
DeSantis doing the right thing in
Florida or Elon Musk appropriately
labeling NPR state-sponsored media which
they had on their own freaking website
until they took it down a couple of days
ago if you call them out and do the
right thing people start coalescing
around that that is the winning model
that's what we got to keep going with be
above The Fray I'm gonna do a I'm going
to try to do an even better job I think
I do a basically decent job of it but
I'm going to try to stay above The Fray
when it comes to some of the uh the
Trump DeSantis attack stuff because I
want it was very clear to me last night
being in a room with all of these uh
these good people
that we don't want to add fuel to this
fire and you know it's interesting I
don't know if you for those of you that
are offline a little bit more you may
not have noticed Trump has really
shifted his tone even in the last couple
days I think he realized that the
attacks on DeSantis are not working that
just screaming that he's a globalist and
a rhino it's not working so I think
there are good things that could happen
there because then have an honest fight
not like the crazy fight but the point
is and this is true for DeSantis it's
true for Elon Musk
I would argue it's true for me and it's
probably true for you if you make
positive change you get more popular and
once you get it's not because it's a
popularity contest but once you start
doing the right thing it becomes
infectious other people start doing it
right and then a whole bunch of us doing
do it and then maybe just maybe we could
turn this whole freaking thing around
[Music]
oh